so say it's a great honor please welcome
mr. Gary Vaynerchuk
on stage
hello well everyone we're so grateful
again Gary thank you
welcome to some grateful to be back yeah
how are you Stockholm still a little
energy in the afternoon I like it oh so
that's interesting I've been actually
looking at a lot of business plans very
similar to it I think that uh charging
for a product is a good idea so I'm in
the camp of saying go [ __ ] yourself free
so I think that there's an opportunity
to monetize niche content in a monthly
subscription based way you look at a
very conservative talk show host in the
US Glenn Beck left Fox News went online
has hundreds of thousands of people
paying him eight dollars a month that's
a good business model I think you know
from the success I had with Wine Library
TV when I retired last year I probably
got and I have them all saved in case I
want to do this probably about four to
five thousand people who said they'll
pay three bucks an episode just to get
me back into the game so yeah I think
there's always a place for quality
content that people will pay for I think
freemium is a great business model but
charging right from the beginning makes
a hell of a lot of sense so I liked it
what is it that you're focusing on at
the moment so since I was here last year
the book had just come out I in that
summer I stopped doing Wine Library TV
so after five and a half years of doing
daily Wine content I stopped and put all
my focus to Baner media which is the
social media agency my brother AJ and I
started in September when I kind of took
over the the realm we were at 24 people
we're now at 125 so I've been in very
head down operations mode we've landed
some very big clients like Oprah Winfrey
and the National Football League and big
big clients of PepsiCo and GE and so
we're doing quite well
we have ambition to be the biggest
social media agency in the world
I know that you like to talk about the
reality of things so what is the reality
of the market right now well I think the
reality the markets different in
different places you know you know I
heard I was here yesterday and heard
that money was king right that you know
whereas in the US there's a major bubble
right now for start-up culture I mean
every idiot with a half of an idea is
getting a hundred thousand dollars or a
million dollars to try it and so what we
have in the current reality in the u.s.
is a lot of bad businesses being funded
and a lot of people gonna lose a lot of
money on the flip side the Internet has
never been more mature
there's users you know you've never been
able to scale as quickly the cost
because the Amazon services and other
products are so down and hitting the
marketplace
so unlike the 2000 bubble where it'll
blow up and two or three people are
gonna be left I think this next bubble
burst will still have a lot of people
that make a lot of money there's a lot
of good businesses out there and so it's
kind of a mix the thing that bothers me
the most is in the u.s. everybody's
celebrating when you raise money my dad
taught me from our Eastern Europe that
the day you borrow money is the worst
day of your life so you know everybody's
cheering oh I raised 8 million dollars
I'm like you should be [ __ ] scared you
know you know but they don't think of it
that way they don't realize the
repercussions you got a lot of young
entrepreneurs and business people who
are like well I'll raise this money and
if it doesn't work out the experience
was worth it what they don't realize is
if they lose investors money they're not
gonna be able to get it so fast the
second time around and so I think a lot
about legacy and brand equity and I
think that a lot of people are burning
theirs with a half good idea because
they know money is cheap right now when
you look at social media and the role it
played I got a good question on Twitter
here if you're really honest with
yourself and look back in the mirror too
and before Facebook did you foresee the
role social media will play for
e-commerce for e-commerce you you know
guys I'll be very honest with you I
don't really try to be in the prediction
business right I make them cuz it's fun
but I don't really give a [ __ ] of
predicting I try to execute
on the early stages of something
happening so I mean I didn't even have a
computer until I was 20 years old I
thought I was gonna open up 500 liquor
stores and then I heard couch the
Internet right and so I was like wait a
minute this is interesting
I think people spend too much time
worrying about predicting instead of
executing in the current way my big beef
right now with all our clients and a lot
of businesses I think people are
marketing like it's 2006 when it's 2012
I don't want to mark it like it's 2018
because I'm not gonna sell anything I
want to mark it like it's 2012 and so
did I think Facebook would be well no
not when there was a million people on
it but when I realized they opened it up
from just college and people were
jumping on it did I realize Twitter was
gonna be such a factor in my career in O
six I mean everybody thought it was [ __ ]
and I thought it was awesome so I bet
all my time on it I guess at some level
I did but not you know I don't think the
brain has the capacity of like truly
understanding I mean we're all gonna be
selling with Holograms and augmented
reality and all sorts of things that we
can't even think about right now we'll
all be paying for every product with our
phone I mean there's gonna be a million
things we're going to do I have no
interest in being right
I have interested in execution and so
when something like Pinterest comes out
two years ago I'm playing with it to see
if there's value for me in the current
state of business not six years from now
when I angel invest I'll guess for six
years from now but knowing the crowd
that's here from a practical standpoint
you know it's grossly negligent to not
be marketing on a Facebook fan page in
2012 I'm you're an idiot if you're not
now the ROI doesn't happen as fast as it
did in other places so when people don't
get fast results in six months on social
media they give up and that honestly is
the most exciting thing for me because
the more people make mistakes the more
room I have to eat the cake well if I
can follow up on that in with your
practical mindset in 2012
do you think social commerce is a term
that is just a fad does it matter to you
or how do you relate to that term do you
think it's gonna be around I've got
several people asking that so here's
what I think you know I I grew up in a
retail business and a bricks and mortar
and
I watched winelibrary.com in 1997 if
you're in the retail business you know
that word of mouth matters word of mouth
is how we get customers to not
understand that we're and by the way let
me just say this I really don't care
about the word social media or social
commerce I mean we called social media
web 2.0 five minutes ago um all we're
really talking about is the Internet the
way the Internet is acting now you want
to lump Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr
and Pinterest and Instagram into a thing
called social media knock your [ __ ]
socks off but it doesn't matter to me
what I'm interested in is where are
people and how do I make them do
something so that I can sell them
something the the reality of the
marketplace is we right now are selling
more wine because of Pinterest and
Facebook and Twitter combined so does
that matter to me yeah but it also means
that we figured out how to use Pinterest
better it's also early less people are
doing it right it's also in my opinion
the wishlist of the internet which is
commerce driven to begin with you know I
mean people people are who we sell
product to if they're talking to each
other they potentially could be talking
about our products and services to to
disregard it because you haven't figured
it out or even worse this is what really
pisses me off to disregard social
because all you wanted to do on social
media is spam your followers until they
can't breathe is idiotic
you know it's like saying is a piano a
good tool for me it's not because I
don't know how to [ __ ] play a piano
but Elton John's made a lot of money
because of it and so the platform's
right just most of the people here and
most of people in the world suck [ __ ] at
it because they're trying to sell too
hard through it you know what I mean I
have some questions I mean oh you heard
so many social ecommerce experts in
sintra or is social media experts is
saying you have to give value yeah on
Twitter or on Facebook and then two
minutes later you see I I have a coffee
it's nice yeah same person yep
I mean how do you view that there's so
much crap in those showers yeah it
depends on what kind of personality you
are right like Kim Kardashian makes
fifty million dollars a year in America
for putting makeup on her face and
that brings value because people find
that entertaining I really don't give a
[ __ ] if Robert Scoble is having a coffee
but maybe some people do I surely don't
think that my fans really care if I'm
very upset about a New York Jets game
but somehow through putting out a lot of
content I created context where they do
care about that
I think value comes in many different
ways you know some people are just more
entertaining some people are just
prettier right you know nobody wants to
see me in a dress but plenty of people
click a link that has a pretty girl in
it right so there's a lot of ways to do
that
some people want to hear about
up-and-coming trends so they follow that
person value comes in many shapes or
sizes finding how to bring value and how
to build an audience around that is the
trick but also talking about an
increasing maturing US would you say
that it's go it's much faster today that
that insurance the for Pinterest or when
you think yeah the speed of wind speed
yeah I mean Facebook had like four years
to figure it out right Twitter had like
three poor Foursquare Dennis Crowley
after years like did you figure it out
you know now sites launched two minutes
Socialcam and vide right now which I'm
hot on you know how are they gonna
monetize I mean these companies are 16
seconds old it's like asking all of us
when we were 10 years old to be good
citizens
it takes time yeah I think the maturity
thing is quite interesting I actually
think there's huge opportunity if you're
smart about this I think too many of us
are pooh-poohing things in their infant
State it takes time I mean look the
great story about this is reddit versus
dick took reddit six years to kind of
win that current battle and so things
take time and yeah I think it's kind of
ludicrous to ask these platforms to
monetize so quickly on the flip side as
early adopters and as business people
you have to go where users are and when
something like social camp can pick up
30 million users you know in just a
heartbeat you have to go in tests I'm
always blown away by smaller companies
not going and testing the water or
trying to find their ROI being nimble
and being fast is really the game of
business and I think people poopoo it or
they wait for it to hit scale when you
wait for it to hit scale you
pay a lot more money for it and so I
think there's a lot of ways people are
looking at this incorrectly and you said
somewhere that the middleman is dying is
that correct
and yeah there's a lot of middleman
where and the or you said are you
starting a vineyard in California yeah I
mean I you know I think the middleman is
very much in trouble I think that you
have to pay attention anybody who's a
retailer in here you need to pay
attention to what's happening in the US
market with things like Warby Parker or
bonobos many of you probably are
starting to realize it as well or take a
page out of Isis Barbie amazing so you
know take a page out of take a page out
of what's happening with Walmart and
Target these are exceptionally mature
retailers in the u.s. Tesco why are they
50% private label well because if you're
selling somebody's product in an
Internet age where everybody has
information at their fingertips all of a
sudden you're playing for a race to the
bottom in price and free shipping and
all these other variables so I would I
would I would
passionately tell a lot of the retailers
in the room here now if you're reselling
I highly recommend thinking about a very
strategic and smart private label or
creating your own brand program because
you're gonna need to hedge and create
that profit margin because your margins
and the other sectors are going to go
down don't forget how small ecommerce
really is in the u.s. it's 11 percent of
commerce but up from nine took us 15
years to get the nine one year to get to
11 when this market really gets big I
mean looking around the crowd here
there's a lot of young people here
nobody's retiring next year do you know
what this is all gonna look like in five
and ten years when we got 40% of the
people buying on commerce how big the
pots gonna be but how much information
and how savvy the consumer is if you're
just battling on price or you think your
SEO is gonna work you're out of your
[ __ ] mind so how important is this
the strategy I mean a lot of people
talking about the spread in social
commerce and what do you think about
that the strategy yeah well I think
everything needs strategy right you know
if you don't have a strategy you only
have short-term victories you know it's
why I talk
about things four or five years early
because I kind of try to play as many
chess moves as possible now that gets
you in trouble let me give you my story
in 1998 I decided that mobile phones
were gonna be the future right and then
by the year 2000 and just two years
every person's gonna walk into my store
with their mobile phone take a picture
of the UPC know every price of that wine
in the world and then I would have to
lower my prices so in 1998 to get ahead
of that to have my strategy I lowered
all our margins and all our prices
because I wanted to be able to be
sustainable by the time that happened
it's 2012 it still hasn't happened so I
was wrong
it was our strategy but the world did
become more price driven around the same
product and it did help us grow the
execution was wrong the overall strategy
was close I was too early and probably
gave away more margin than I needed to
but I wanted to become more nimble kind
of athletes to be successful if you
don't have strategy you you will there's
only one other way to really win which
is to be extremely nimble have micro
strategies do things that feel right do
it but the second you taste something
adjust at some level that's my overall
strategy which is understand
philosophically what I'm trying to
accomplish as positioning the brand
whether it was myself whether that was
my store whether that's vaynermedia but
recognize that everything changes in a
heartbeat I mean most of the
conversations that I've had with Pepsi
ge Green Mountain Coffee del Monte foods
this week has been around Pinterest and
Socialcam that's not a word that was
even talked about six months ago we are
living in very fast times so it's
important to understand that on the flip
side knowing this audience at this point
there are very practical business women
men and women in this crowd to bet on
the next new shiny thing prematurely
does not have value short-term if you
cannot afford it then you shouldn't do
it if you can then you should that's
really an important way to think about
it at some level though you have to
understand that social commerce is about
the customer not about you and that's
where I think a lot of people struggle
it's always about your offer your
product twitter.com slash search is the
single most powerful I mean
I should say here now Twitter Twitter
you guys are a bunch of [ __ ] you
have the best product in social media
for business and you never talk about it
Thank You twitter.com slash search is a
marketer and retailers dream the you
know the fact that people are putting
out content about their interests and
their potential buying and the things
they like and you can jump into that
engage that conversation without being
the jerk off and trying to sell to them
right away and then bring awareness to
your brand is incredible and should be
done it's scale but people continue not
to do it because the fact of the matter
is this room and the entire business
world is petrified of what we're on the
dawn of which is one on one marketing
we're here guys one-on-one marketing is
here we just don't want to admit it
because it's hard it's quite hard and
the way you actually win in one-on-one
marketing is spending on people in your
organization to scale the caring and the
one-on-one engagement not on the bad
platforms that we use for retargeting
and all that stuff
customer acquisition has been mapped you
can do that you can retarget sem SEO
Facebook Ads good but what you're all
gonna care about in the next decade
because of social because word-of-mouth
matters is retention and percentage of
wallet spent and lifetime value and
those are the things we're all gonna be
battling on and that takes heart and
soul not just a good algorithm and UI in
UX well an extension of the one on
one-on-one marketing approach is to say
no to customers like Seth Godin says
fire your customers do that Seth Godin
says fire your customers in a very b2b
mentality which I think has a lot of
truth in a b2c mentality you're getting
customers that are firing you at scale
anyway I think you really have to
understand what that means
so saying no to customers is maybe not
listening to them at what price you
should sell a product because you read a
lot of reviews that say it should be
cheaper they'll always say that but you
know to me the customers King anything I
can do for a customer I'm interested in
bending over backwards yes there's a lot
of truth to that statement but you have
to put that in the context of the
business matter where we're firing cuz
vaynermedia because they're too much of
a headache for what they pay us at the
end yeah you talk a lot about the
contents marketing how can you work
towards quality in content how can you
make it valuable easy make it valuable
right
and so like let's think about that for a
second again if you look at ecommerce
companies and a lot of people that have
brands putting out content again they're
stuck in a television mentality and
they're making it about them not about
the user so I mean I lived it I started
a wine show and instead of making a QVC
and just selling wine I made it a
service and I talked about wine in
general and educated and most insanely
in 2006 remember this is six years ago I
panned my own product because I wanted
to make it valuable and by panning and
saying this wine tastes like the horse's
ass during a rainy storm it's disgusting
and people say well I don't want to
drink that right
that brought value to my end-users and
built trust I'm blown away by how many
people are not putting out content that
brings value to the user
you know demonstration videos there's a
lot of one-off products on the web doing
quite well right now because they put a
QR code or a UPC or a URL on the product
and when you go there it shows you how
to use the product via video
instructional stuff for a lot of people
fashion shows for fashion brand there's
ways to bring value again we're sitting
here talking a lot about tactical stuff
which I want to talk about at length but
I it's imperative for me since I slept
over here for people to understand
something this is a mentality and for
the last hundred years retailers and
brands have not cared about the customer
I promise you and for everybody here is
like I love my customer no you don't you
love your data and you're looking at it
and you love your business people have
not truly loved the customer and very
honestly I'm not mother Teresa I also
would have not loved the customer if I
did not recognize five years ago because
of the maturity of the internet and
sites that we call social media are now
being built to connect consumers
together in a way that eventually at
scale will come
completely dictate the success of your
business we will only be marketing to
our communities and they'll be marketing
to their friends
we will not be renting from ad networks
and newspapers and television to buy
attention we will have attention and
market to it and how we treat them will
show how they will bring attention and
bring fans into our funnel to be
relevant them to create that kind of
value last time you were here I believe
you spoke about analysis you need to
analyze all the data is that correct
yeah I mean listen I'm a big fan of IQ
meets EQ data plus emotional intuition
where you think the markets going data
is important but you don't need you
don't always live by it for example how
many people here and this is gonna hurt
my feelings but I'll do it anyway how
many people here have watched an episode
of Wine Library TV raise your hand not
bad
thank you actually I thought thank you
so many of you might know that within
the first 15 seconds when I enter the
show it could come across very obnoxious
right I get very excited I see the light
go I go hello everybody like a very
hyper looking at the data 17% of the
people that watched the show would leave
within the first four seconds cuz they
couldn't handle my energy right because
they thought it was annoying or a
douchebag or a jerk-off right and I was
like [ __ ] that's a lot and I was like
maybe I should change it and I so I
looked at the data over the weekend the
next Monday I came in I'm gonna change
it why am I losing 17% like one of every
five it's nuts and as soon as the light
went on I did it again and I remember
when I was done I was like huh it just
feels right right like staying you know
maybe I'm losing 17% but 83 percent
might find it more valuable and maybe
I'd lose even more and so I wasn't able
to change myself the authenticity of
what it was but data's massively
important and talent is important and
know-how one thing that's always
forgotten in my story is that I'd been
living and breathing the wine business
for 15 years before I episode number one
right so a lot of times people start a
business because they think green is
gonna be good eco-friendly or oh I see
vodka spiking I'll invest in I'll do a
vodka company they're chasing
is not what they're good at so of course
they can't create content around you
know Fitness or flowers or water because
they don't know [ __ ] about it other what
they read they don't really know it and
so expertise really matters at the end
of the day if you're not entertaining or
if you don't have expertise you've got
no shot teaching marketing we talk a lot
about branding defined a strategy who
who are you what do you represent but
with social media companies are told
that they should show the human side and
the involve employees and that means
that a company could mean a hundred
different things do you think people
shouldn't let go of the brand a little
bit no no I think the brand really
really really matters how people how you
perceive your brand and how you story
tell is imperative how people then
receive it and funnel it in their own
way is totally different but you being
authentic and understanding your brand's
positioning to yourself really matters
because you make the decisions you make
around your business based on that and
how you navigate is quite important in
that tightness in navigation really
matters how its then perceived within
all these niches is a totally different
story and is very much happening and
that's fine but you know for if you do
not know the sense of your brand or your
brand story it's very unlikely forever
to have a shot and in terms of
organizing for social media marketing do
you see a lot of companies outsourcing
their voice to PR agencies and/or to
somebody else and what is your take on
that yeah I mean that's what vaynermedia
does we manage content and communities
for a lot of logos and businesses you
know I think it's it's up to you I mean
if people want to keep it in-house
that's fine
III can see value in that I mean that
we've spent a year and a half just of
the first year and a half just
understanding an exercise to be able to
capture voice of clients otherwise you
have no shot and what we were doing we
think we've gotten really good at it and
there's some stability with that because
we're a company not one individual in
the organization that might leave we've
seen that in the u.s. quite a bit where
the star person went to a different
company you know I think there's both
ways to do that I think PR companies
struggle with it because PR is b2b you
know PR is used to pitching editors and
saw behind the scenes this is this is
er b2c is a very different world where
like if you're having a crisis they all
go to your fanpage and spam you it's a
totally different thought process so I
think it takes a different skill set but
I think it's something that people can
outsource if they have the funds you
mentioned that you have been working for
for big companies what do you think
their biggest challenge is right now
within their organisations regarding
this kind of questions because they are
really big you know it's so fun to be in
an e-commerce like i like e-commerce so
much more I feel like there's so much
more organized than big brands I mean
the biggest problem of big brands is
that people don't make business
decisions based on the business they
make business decisions based on their
career okay if you really want to know
the problem they want to get a raise or
they want to appease their boss or my
favorite let's make up [ __ ]
analytics to sell to the tops I have let
me just you know I want to make sure
there's no confusion in Stockholm I have
no interest in being an advocate
pundants of social media I have no
interest my only interest in the human
world when it comes to business is the
cell ship and because I think these
sites do it that's why I pay attention
to it the end I don't want to be the
let's prove it to them I don't I don't
want to [ __ ] prove anything to
anybody
I just want to execute and build
businesses and that's it and so people
are getting way too romantic about
social people in here romantic and then
there's other people that are completely
cynical and they're both wrong it's in
between right it's always in between is
it early absolutely but so many people
in here rely on e-commerce for them this
is an ecommerce summit I spoke in 1996
where it was a business summit and
everybody in America said that consumers
were not going to put credit cards into
a computer how that work out right and
so and then in 2000 I was like this
Google thing I'm telling you Google
AdWords dad do you know what the big
argument was your competitors are gonna
click your Google ads and ride off your
cost how'd that work out right and so
like em everything that all of you are
doing right now just 45 seconds ago some
was saying it was [ __ ] so I highly
recommend you not saying socialist [ __ ]
because first of all sites that have 900
million users or things of that nature
it's tough for it to be [ __ ] you got to
know how to use it the first year I used
Facebook ads we sucked at it you know
why cuz we tried to treat him like
Google Ads and then we started
understanding it was about the visual do
you know that when you buy Facebook ads
if you put a yellow border around the
same ad as a blue border it could
perform 3 4 or 500 times better so maybe
the reason your Facebook ads suck and
you've decided Facebook blows is because
it wasn't a yellow border was a pink
border so what happens is we like to get
on a soapbox and dismiss things very
quickly oh that's stupid oh that doesn't
work and when we had another rule that
were used to that was the rule before
and it doesn't match that rule we
struggle with it people didn't like
direct marketing with Google and stuff
like that because it wasn't like
television and print it was different it
wasn't mass it was narrow right now they
fell in love with it it's efficient it
converts we all know right
but then Facebook came along and they
don't like it because it doesn't convert
as well that's because social isn't
intent to buy or search product it's a
different kind of thing but for branding
it really matters and there's a big
difference between marketers and sales
people and when you're trying to make
sales decision listen the sales people
but when you're making branding and
marketing decisions listen to marketers
yeah so looking at looking ahead of it
yeah what's the next thing I have no
idea okay
thank you right I mean that at some
level here's what I know I'm not gonna
I'm not Nostradamus I don't know what's
gonna come up here's what I do know
mobile is gonna continue to really
really really really matter every
product in our lives is gonna be smart
so if you sell produce and you live in a
world with a smart refrigerator where
we're all very lazy and my refrigerator
just reorders my product for me and I
don't go to the store because it's Ewing
using RFD and you know and technology of
that nature
then it's gonna be really important for
you to penetrate the refrigerator when
the refrigerator starts becoming as
difficult to penetrate as a retail
stores shelves are that's gonna be a lot
of money in play right you know
we will continue to get more social
because we're human beings and we like
to interact if we didn't we wouldn't
have friends and do the things we do so
as the web allows us to do that more
we're gonna do it even more way more
than you even think this is the social
dark ages this is just the beginning so
that will continue to happen but I don't
really know I just know that when I
start seeing spikes you know I just pay
attention to them I'm also very
passionate about restrictions I'm an
angel investor empath
for that reason only 150 friends and
mobile - things I loved that's why it
was attractive to me things that narrow
it because I think we can all agree
there's a shitload of noise and anything
that can curate it and make it cleaner
and tighter and more valuable has a lot
of value to us I also am obsessed with
gaming dynamics Gaming will continue to
grow it will affect all parts of our
lives so I think that that's another
trend that I'm interested in I think I
think retail will go through more stages
I don't know if you guys have been
paying attention to what's going on with
Birchbox or Baba ko or these box of the
month clubs in the US huge phenomenon I
think that's a micro trend that will
have good businesses for next two or
three years there's just a lot of things
that I see but what I'm really proud of
is trying to taste them very early not
going into some room with a PowerPoint
and a whiteboard and explaining why we
should do it just doing it and doing it
hard like really doing it and then
trying to learn from actually you know
it's so funny how many people have the
opinions on social media and they've
never used it a lot of [ __ ] experts
about Twitter who've only tweeted once I
mean that's [ __ ] ridiculous so you
know to me what's important is to
actually get my fingernails dirty so
what I'm good at is sniffing out stuff
early and then playing with it a lot and
then deciding if it's good about it and
because I've had success in consumer
marketing I didn't have a good knack for
thinking about what people may or may
not like but it's not always perfect
what do you think about globalization
when it comes to e-commerce for a couple
of years ago we talked about e-commerce
in the u.s. ecommerce
in the
okay but the last couple of years there
are a lot of US retailers selling in
Europe and and so on yeah I mean you
know I think there's a huge disadvantage
for being an American businessman long
term because American business people
tend to stick just in America and we are
full-pledged globalization opportunities
you look at you know they're very
dismissed and a lot of people call them
copycats but the brothers in Germany who
cloned all the successful US companies
to go and execute in 1314 2014 market
successfully takes work you can
philosophically disagree with the tact
of doing what they're doing and I very
much understand why if you want to be
romantic about innovation and things of
that nature
but I like execution and I also always
scold my American business friends when
they always get on their high horse on
copycat sites or this I'm like you're
[ __ ] American you just think it's all
about America you don't realize how big
the market place in the world is and so
I come to countries that might be
smaller but healthy like this and I
always them they're always like yeah but
you have three humbling don't worry
about what we have worry about how good
you have it you know European
sensibility of like the world is so much
better it's not just an acai low and I
think that that presents enormous
opportunity not to mention that there's
great innovation being done in all over
the world that can work in the US if
that person wants to and if it were you
know has great success opportunities in
the u.s. not to mention that many people
know how to speak English to begin with
I want to see all of my Palo Alto
friends come and go do business in India
or in other places where you know that
you know luckily for them English is
spoken enough but to understand the
consumer big disadvantage so you know
globalization is here there's no huge
opportunity but I don't want people to
get crippled by it
you don't need to go global once you
figure out local first you know I think
people are trying to run before they
have anything I'm looking at so many
startups doing well they're like we're
going to China I'm like [ __ ] you
still suck in America you know so you
know you've got to execute first the
other way around if we're talking about
tebah or 360 buy or them going to yeah
the US yeah I mean I think it's I think
it's a real opportunity I mean you
an amazingly easy place to do business
with it's tough to understand the US
consumer is very unique moves very
quickly so you can't look at SlideShare
presentations and know that's where it's
going you gotta live in it like anything
you want to be successful you've got to
get your hands dirty you want to open a
us-based business don't spend a year
there work for some competitor or
supplier taste it
people underestimate tasting it they
think they're so [ __ ] smart you're
not you have to understand the nuances
every opportunity and growth is the
nuances you want a great business idea
take any business that you know and do
it this much better you'll have a huge
business did you find a particular
Swedish startup or company that you
think has potential or I think if you
had time hiya buddy I haven't done the
homework but you know the fact that
matters it's it's it's just obvious
right I mean there's been successful
companies from around the world in every
parts of the world I haven't done the
homework so I wouldn't want to say
something and then be wrong I try to
keep my mouth shut and stuff I don't
know so I don't have any very
risk-averse right I'm very risk-averse
for being such an extrovert and a
ridiculously over-the-top character and
how I'm positioned in the marketplace
where I'm where I was born which is the
former Soviet Union and growing up with
no money and being an immigrant has made
me dramatically more risk-averse
the only thing is I believe in myself
and I understand one thing
if you don't innovate you're going to
die to be in 2012 and to sit in those
green seats out there and to be an
e-commerce business and to pooh-pooh
social or not think it's good is [ __ ]
stupid it just is it's just so stupid
and that doesn't mean that you should be
using it because it might not be
practical but you should be tasting it
and you should be respecting it because
the innovation on top of it may be
important to you and if you don't have
the sensibility of this wave you have no
shot of writing the next wave Twitter
Cristen for you if you had a million
dollar to spend just a marketing what
would you do it would depend on what I'm
selling okay so you know if I had a
million dollars to spend on marketing it
would completely depend on what I'm
selling
every decision is based on the story or
the product you're selling you always
reverse engineer always you know one
thing for sure I would spend on if I had
a if I had an act of business right now
and I had a million dollars to spend on
marketing I would spend it on stale or
dead customers of my current business
let me say that again I think the
biggest opportunity for everybody in
this room is they have a database of
customers who are inactive or not
converting if you have an email service
email how many people here do email
marketing for their business just raise
your hands so for half of you you're not
converting your email at a hundred
percent open rate and a hundred percent
click-through what's even more
interestingly is you probably have data
on customers who bought who've been
inactive for a year or more that to me
is an incredibly interesting place to
spend marketing dollars on to go back
and try to get business from people that
have already cracked the hardest nut
which is to become a first-time customer
I think people are way too much in
acquisition mode and not in you know
retention mode I think everybody wants
to go hunting
I recommend more farming I love that
message
yeah real to talk about that I it's it's
why I think I'm successful um you know
it's
I don't think everybody's born with
gratitude you know in their DNA I'm
super glad I am it's what makes me
so customer focus and it's been my
biggest advantage in my life it also
really you know I don't know how you
could get gratitude you know there's no
way to teach a become grateful do it you
know you can't really do that but boy if
you feel like you are I highly recommend
trying to evoke that emotion more often
it is literally the singular backbone of
me being so happy in my life I'm just
grateful and I keep it very basic I'm
grateful that the people I care about
are healthy and so you know it's really
funny when you have a big bad business
moment or something really bad happens
in business if you just make pretend
that the reverse of that happen so you
lost a six million dollar account if you
make pretend that you gained a six
million dollar account but you got a
phone call
that your parent is sick or dying or you
lost your child or sound like that it
puts you in the right mindset very
quickly I'm sorry go extreme but that's
kind of what I do I am a pretty much a
99.9% happy dude because something
happens what I'm dealing with something
bad that quickly puts my brain into
putting things in perspective being
grateful for the fact that I was born in
the last dictatorship in Europe right
now there's one dictatorship left in
Europe
it's called Belarus I was born there you
know and I was traded for wheat by the
United States to Russia I mean during
the Cold War I got real lucky and then
on top of that I was born to like the
greatest mom of all time that's luck you
know because my dad he wasn't born to
the greatest mom my grandma is crazy so
I'm just very him I'm just very very
grateful and then I was gifted intuitive
business DNA which keeps you alive very
easily in a capitalist world like the
u.s. if I stayed in Belarus I have a
feeling I would have been in jail or
dead so I'm just very very very grateful
and completely driven by it and try to
give as much as to others because I'm
good I don't need I don't need more
money or more fame or more stuff I'm
good I mean I want to buy the New York
Jets so I do need a couple of billion
dollars but but but not really I just
want to kind of keep doing what I'm
doing there's an amazing feeling when
you get an email from somebody who says
you've changed their business life or
her life that feels good to me and
that's why I think I continue to speak
and write that that feeling is a hell of
a lot more interesting than anything you
can get financially thank you thank you
it's awesome
I don't by the way on that note thank
you so much it's very nice
on that note when you shift your mindset
to retention and growth from your active
customers and you start putting your
marketing dollars into people to take
care of them like calling customers I
told the group earlier we now call every
single person that is unsubscribed from
our email service and we're able to keep
49% of them on by just thanking them for
ever being on by not making an offer by
not trying to convince them why by
calling them and saying thank you for
ever being part of our team
servus we really appreciate it half of
them Rhys absque Rybak and then spend 7x
over the next six months of what they
thought the prior six months three
minutes four minutes effort is
underrated and so to the note that you
guys just clapped which I appreciate
when that becomes your philosophy and
business it also feels really good when
you're 55 65 75 and you look back at how
you did business you're gonna feel much
more proud that you gave to your
customers then that you retargeted them
from a banner ad and got them into the
funnel not that that's bad cuz you have
to do that too and on the family path
you know you're right about your
daughter is it Misha or yes yeah but do
you see her growing up as an
entrepreneur of course you're gonna tell
I'm gonna say something right now that I
firmly believe is gonna happen I swear
to God I think Misha is going to be the
President of the United States of
America because I think I could have
been president the United States of
America I wasn't born in Russia so she
has my DNA and I you know it's gonna be
different I grew up having to hustle for
everything right when I was 12 and I
wanted Sega Genesis my mom looked at me
and said go buy it so I had it I was
always dad she has very extroverted DNA
but she's gonna grow up in a very
different society she's gonna grow up in
private schools in Manhattan and and all
her friends are gonna be Chris Sacca and
Mark Zuckerberg kids and like it's gonna
be ridiculous she's gonna live in a
totally different world than I did and
and I'm curious for myself how much
hunger to succeed that that opportunity
is gonna take from her or is the DNA
gonna be powerful enough to still make
her want to I look at my friend Ben lair
Ben lair as the founder of Thrillist
in the u.s. his dad was very successful
he grew up in Manhattan well off and
he's still hungry and hustling and that
gives me hope but I know 50,000 others
that look the other way I don't know she
turns 3 in a couple of weeks it's hard
for me to predict the
I feel like I feel like I feel like I
just went through nursery school that's
an incredibly amazing process in uh in
New York and they're asking these
questions and they're analyzing her and
I'm looking at them I'm like she's
[ __ ] too you know so you know I'm not
sure we're showing up here's what I know
I believe in parenting more than
anything more than environment more than
anything and I know that Lizzie and I
are gonna give it our all
yeah Center 7 University yeah so we had
a I would say internet legend here
yesterday you almost on hold so he said
that we need to break out from the
slavery from from Facebook and Google it
said we had lost our identity we don't
know in our own data anymore but your
what you take on that and when do you
believe what's gonna happen in the
future what's its friend I always laugh
when people make that argument okay
because we sure didn't stop American
Express or Visa or MasterCard you know
this is not a new business my friends
anything that brings us value we're
thrilled to give away that stuff god
bless you you know honestly I don't feel
any lighter load in my pocket because
Facebook makes a dollar 23 on me right
though as it becomes more of the
conversation is it conceivable that
somebody can start a social network that
you know shares in the wealth with you
people like to think that here's the
problem the original people in a
community dictate the DNA and the
overall experience if tomorrow somebody
made a real strong play and said we're
gonna share revenue with you sure if
you're using it we'll give you money
the original pioneers the forefathers of
that social network are gonna be
affiliate marketers and they're gonna be
lowest-common-denominator marketing
people and it's gonna create a tone in
there that is not going to be Adventist
to more people coming in it's gonna be
more of the ghetto then you know the
countryside and so it sounds romantic
and it's really awesome to come up and
say we're slaves of Facebook and Google
but where we slaves of MySpace I mean
where we slaves a Friendster will go
where we want to go you know and we'll
go where our friends are and so will
there be fragmentation sure is there a
danger for Facebook
we need a recycling every five to seven
eight years because all of a sudden we
look at our Facebook friends and our not
our friends sure it's why I invested
impact I believe in that right but I
don't think we have this I don't think
how many people here really are
devastated that Facebook is making money
or Google's making money on your data
you're truly you're bothered raise your
hand so I think it's romantic it's kind
of like remember when Foursquare came
out and they said don't check into
places because people will rob your
house if you check in I think there's a
lot of things that are said that
customers really don't give a [ __ ] about
including let me give you a big one
privacy that's why there's gonna be so
much money in this stuff
we really don't care about privacy
outside of a couple of things
and don't forget listen I'm not being
naive to this my parents and when I
speak about this in other countries
besides the US yes maybe not in the US
let me say this again my parents were 23
years old when we moved to America I
lived in a Soviet household my parents
the day my dad found out that his
address was on Google he cried for an
hour he was devastated they respect
privacy more than anything the reason we
don't care about privacy is as long as
nobody can steal our money and we can't
get it back or hurt us or our loved ones
we're not going to care and I have a
dirty secret for you the most underrated
brand in the world is the human being we
are much much much much much better than
you think we are the problem is the
evening news has told us how bad we are
for the last 50 years when you watch the
news it's not about all the awesome [ __ ]
that we do for each other
every day it's about the one rogue
person that decided to shoot somebody by
percentage we are incredibly good people
we are that kind of race humans and that
is why we will not care about privacy
because horrible things are not
happening at scale in fact I would argue
that the lack of privacy is making us a
nicer and better society because the
kidnapper now knows that everybody has a
phone and can catch them on film and so
I actually think that this lack of
privacy is
causing us to be better when it comes to
this personal perspective and human
beings it brings it to bring sisters
personal branding which is a hot topic
and Jews what is your take on that and
how do you think corporations should act
in order in order to hire people should
that come in with cloud school or
followers and things like that should
they ask them to subordinate themselves
and become a company person or should
you coexist yeah I mean you know that
second part that last thing you said
that sounds like communism so I never
believed in that I always laugh at
American companies they're like we're
gonna suppress our people in like geez I
thought I left Russia you know so you
know I think that's delicate subject um
you know it all depends on how you play
I continue to believe that when you see
innovation come you use it to go on the
offense instead of trying to fight it
off because you lose we can all go read
I mean there's some amazing stories if
you want to learn about how innovation
really is a fun thing to watch go read
the stories about how the people that
were in the horse business acted when
Henry Ford created the car you know they
bet more on horses they you know they
did everything they could they lost and
so trying to suppress people and not let
them use Facebook and things of that
nature are gonna make you lose your best
people and they're gonna go to cultures
that allow them to do that so that's not
gonna be a winning battle it's about
finding the right balance you know I'm
not a big big fan of clout because I
think the data is still very premature
but the concept is interesting
understanding influence is fascinating
clearly I'd be a hypocrite if I didn't
believe in personal brand I've ridden it
very well for the last five years
there's value in it from an
organizational standpoint it's a tricky
line because if you build somebody up
you build somebody up and they can leave
you don't kind of own that that's scary
which is believe it or not I'm gonna go
very weird on this which is why I tell a
lot of corporations to create animated
characters I always tell them Mickey
Mouse isn't going anywhere
so you know what you build Branden is
very important which is why I believe
we're living through the humanization of
logos I think logos are starting to act
human from the work we're doing with
Vayner people are willing to interact
with Nike or or your each tail business
the way they are with a person
giving that logo a personality's fun
because no matter who leaves you still
own that and from a business perspective
I think that's practical and smart
advice
mm-hmm Sugata another not a Twitter
question here for you sure what are the
two basic things to live by when diving
into social media as a small business so
I mean here's my thoughts from from a
very tactical standpoint Facebook and
Twitter are necessity twitter.com slash
search if you're not going to
twitter.com slash search everyday and
searching your business your handle or
the products you sell and then engaging
those conversations you're leaving
tremendous amounts of business on the
table Facebook Fanpage
bringing value whether its content
entertainment or product information or
discussion opportunities to build a
community are the two eyes the second
place that I think you really have to do
but the biggest thing that's going on
right now my friends is that 99% of the
businesses on social media right now are
doing it poorly because they're either
treating it like a television network or
they're treating it like their email
newsletter it's just way too skewed to
push marketing and this is all about
pulling people in and getting lifetime
value on the flip side the other thing
that I would highly recommend is mapping
your active community your active
customers mapping their social profiles
in a CRM and marketing to them around
their interest not around what they buy
from you that's probably the most
interesting thing we're doing right now
we're mapping who people are and we're
looking at the things they're tweeting
about and then we're sending offers to
them incorporating the stories of their
lives we literally are segmenting our
clients into sports fans and are sending
wine emails that are referencing the
game from last night and they convert
better so we've never lived through a
time where we're you know Facebook and
Twitter owned our data guess what I can
get all the data I want you know you can
search it out you just have to do the
work and so we want our data out there
us putting our data out there makes our
lives better I want to be targeted to I
only
want to see New York Jets and wine and
Lionel Richie ads I want them to be
about the things I like I don't want to
see ads around you know Pepsi or bras or
flowers I want my interest so I think we
want to be marketed to I think that um I
would highly recommend mapping your
current clientele get there you know one
ways to induce them to give you the
Twitter handle another way is to search
it you know another advantage of being
in a smaller country and start
understanding the interest graph not
just the retail graph and use that to
monetize on that subject of getting to
know your customers searching on Twitter
is more by serendipity you discover
something but have you thought about
getting involved in crowdsourcing to
systematize and having people vote on
ideas up and down yeah I think I think
you know I bucket crowdsourcing into
gamification I think those things work
but I will tell you something
I'd much rather listen to my customer
than listen to my customer let me
explain the difference listening to my
customer is them in their natural
habitat and me watching what they're
about asking them to collectively come
up with something and then having to
listen to them you know back to Henry
Ford Henry Ford said if I listen to my
customer I would have made a faster
horse right so I think it's very
dangerous I think it's important to hear
your customer but never necessarily
listen to them so that's kind of how I
want natural habitat more so than
forcing something like what wine do you
guys want oh I don't know and all I'm
singing in this different mindset
instead of watching them and saying oh I
drank a rose a this week and I loved it
that's real yeah well when it comes to
Ford
Scott Monte comes to mind yes it coming
not from the car industry but being
brought in yes social media expert yeah
do you think other car companies and
other traditional companies should do
the same thing or should they train
people internally both work I mean I
think this is a sports analogy there's
teams that have great minor-league
systems and they draft well and they go
well and there's other teams that do
that and then get a free agent and
works sometimes it doesn't I think both
can work I think what's really important
is to really know the DNA of your
company really understand what you're
trying to accomplish not just do social
media because you have to or because I
stood up here and said it's idiotic not
to if you don't feel it and you don't
believe it knock yourself out
I've spent my whole life being told I
was wrong going with my intuitive nature
proving it out right so if you know if
you think everything that I've been
talking about for the last hours a crock
of [ __ ] god bless go do your thing you
know I I think that's what's important
instead of saying oh for did that lets
us do that several of our speakers that
summit have been talking about the
importance of keeping the costs down
what are your thoughts about that yeah I
mean listen you know overhead is you
know half the equation right I think
keeping costs down is smart but I think
that every person in this room is under
investing in their current customer
everyone and so it depends in the life
cycle that you're in my intuition is
could be wrong that the people you know
who were giving that advice were either
in very very big companies or very very
small companies a lot of people and most
people are somewhere in between that's
actually when you probably need to spend
the most against it it just matters what
you're trying to accomplish when I was
building wine library I wanted to build
a big company so guess what
I kept costs high because I needed
people vaynermedia we have a hundred and
twenty-five employees for like five
minutes old guess what that's not
keeping costs down that's investing in
the future so when you keep costs down
if you take that the wrong way in the
crowd it's going to stunt your growth
because the people payroll is its
payroll in advertising so it's awareness
and execution which oh by the way are
the two things you need to build a
business I think it's very very
dangerous advice as is invest invest
invest it's something in between it also
comes down to if you're owning your own
business how much do you want to make
you know twenty nine years old I was
making you know thirty eight thousand
dollars a year because I wanted the
money to go back into my business it was
mine so it depends on you know if you're
an operator and your bonus depends on it
you're gonna want the more
to be higher but then you're slowing the
growth patterns I mean listen I come
from the school you know I'm being
polite to the people that gave that
advice I come from the school of
investing your face off as much as you
can afford keeping as little as possible
you know for a rainy day and to pay your
bills but every other dollar back into
the business because that's how you can
grow I have a Twitter question for you
again yeah what do you think of
ecommerce in you Eastern Europe you know
I haven't you know I'm better knowledged
in Western Europe and China and other
places for e-commerce I know that
customer service suck [ __ ] in Eastern
Europe so I think that's a big
opportunity for me like I find that
exciting but I don't really really know
sorry do you subscribe to this Happiness
culture with Zappos and talking about
being a little bit weird I'm having fun
at work and in or its translated into
social media to encourage your employees
to be a little bit non professional to
not always be so serious yes and no the
answer is yes having a good work
atmosphere is all I care about
it's what's brought me success but
recognizing that different people have
different needs as important so if
you've got I've got some great I mean we
have a ridiculous culture we have here's
vaynermedia our vacation policy is you
can take every day off if you want now
if you do I'm gonna fire you but you
know but we have no vacation policy
dress code is all over the place nothing
is being monitored in a traditional way
all I want is results and more
importantly we're monitoring people some
people clamor and they like it standing
desks all sorts of things other people
are more introverted so we give them
areas where they can be quiet the
developers you know developers in the
house you know they don't want to hear a
[ __ ] they want their headphones on in
their a corner and leave me alone three
screens and I'm out right so I think
what's most important is not doing
one-size-fits-all I think it's nice to
have a mantra and I think Tony's done a
great job but what Tony's really talking
about is good atmosphere in the building
Tony's a little weird that's why they're
a little weird for me it's us
right like if somebody leaves the office
at 5:00
they're like scorned by my face right
but my thing is hustle working hard
which is why people probably stay six
seven eight nine ten I think companies
take the DNA of the leadership I really
really really do but I do believe in
Tony's philosophy and I believe in it's
very similar to mine which is a happy
atmosphere at work is the whole thing
the whole thing and it's little things
it's little tactical things we have now
a wheel of fun every time we get a new
client I bring everybody in front of the
wheel of fun and I spin it and everybody
gets a prize $10 gift card to iTunes or
pizza party or open bar you try to do
things that are fun we're very young
company so that's fun open bars fun for
them if the company was older maybe it'd
be a spa treatment you know I think
you've got an I think it's very
individual much like I believe that
we're in the dawn of one-on-one
marketing on the consumer level I feel
like we're in the dawn of one-on-one
engagement within your own organization
and everybody's different and as much as
you can tailor to them then you have a
chance to have global retention one of
our participant yes turday so that all
good entrepreneurs wants to make the
world a little better
how will we animate media make the word
better yeah so first of all I think
that's not true first of all like same
guy that I think it I I think that's a
romantic thing that entrepreneurs want
to say first entrepreneurs want to make
[ __ ] money
right cuz that's why they're
entrepreneurs really you know if they
want to make the world better go be a
philanthropist or go work for a [ __ ]
shelter that's horseshit
that's just romantic mumbo-jumbo
[ __ ] now it's a nice by-product I
sure like the things I do that are nice
but it's not what wires an entrepreneur
an entrepreneur is wired to buy [ __ ] and
sell [ __ ] and then they figure out they
get bored because they get so good at it
then they start giving it away and doing
the right thing as they mature but
that's another story I heard that too I
don't believe that at all and all my
Silicon Valley friends all the ones you
read on TechCrunch love to say at
they're full of [ __ ]
sorry so that's that you know I think
that I think the best way in business to
make the world a little bit better is by
creating jobs
by treating your customers right as you
can by making as much money as possible
so that you can do the other good things
you know if you're making not a lot of
money you're probably not going to a
charity ball because you're probably
working so running a healthy business I
think you're seeing that a lot now with
TOMS shoes and like pencils of promise
and Warby Parker people are building
businesses with this kind of hook of
doing good along the way I think that's
great I hate when people do it for the
sake of doing it as a as a front for
what they really want which is cash in
their pocket on the flip side I think a
lot of I'll give you great example I
would never ever think about doing a
business model that would have a charity
component but now that I've seen it I've
thought about it from a business
standpoint and it's a bipartisan passion
about because family members have passed
away or have problems so now it's in my
mind and I'm excited about that because
people will act on that and it's you
know I would have never gone into the
charity world because I'm an
entrepreneur but now there's my way to
do that without just giving away my
money which always leads to way for me
to create more value so I think that the
blend of doing good listen we're living
under a microscope you remember what I
said earlier I promise you a lot of
these people would not be doing these
things if they did wouldn't get the
articles in the press clippings we're
living in a world where we're all on and
when the microphone and when the cameras
on you're always the best version of
yourself
when that becomes 24/7 365 to the whole
world we're all gonna elevate our game
and I think that's attractive for the
short term I'm sure there's some yang to
that yang but it's gonna take 4050 years
so I'm not so sold I'll see it anyway
Gary yep do you want to come back to
Sweden yes thank you guys
thank you so much thank you thanks so
much thank you so much thank you so much
thank you so much